würdet ihr eure antworten lassen für 200
euro das ist echt schon verdammt hart
dass sich das kommando für 20 euro auf
den mund küssen oder 45 euro auf der
straße schwenken service wird sonderlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute es
ist wieder so ein zeitpunkt gekommen in
der geschichte von youtube wo man auf
die startseite geht eine gewisse arten
videos einen gewissen trend sieht und
sich denkt wer erschießt mich dann bitte
hierzu meisten von euch leute sind
wahrscheinlich schon ne weile dabei
haben schon die höchst behinderten
trends aller zeiten gesehen
sie haben baden gesehen sie haben 24
stunden videos gesehen sie haben drei
uhr nachts videos gesehen
es gibt neuen hammer und zwar die
sozialen experimente sind zurück leute
wer hat sie vermisst kann sich einer von
euch melden kurz werden wir irgendwie
wichtig so keiner tatsächlich wurden
soziale experimente das hat eine
aktuelle studie von halt dein maul
institut auch belegt nicht vermisst in
youtube deutschland trotzdem sind sie
jetzt zurück und es geht jetzt darum was
leute für geld machen super dabei sind
einige klassiker entstanden wie für 100
euro umfassen
wasser spritzt machen wo spritzwand
täten anfassen wasser kurz kurzfristig
oder es spricht nichts oder für 200 euro
anpassen
auch schön leute wenn man sich diese
titel einfach so anschaut dazu muss man
eigentlich nicht sagen oder spannend
daran ist aber dass es jetzt eine gruppe
von jungen männern in deutschland gibt
die fest davon ausgehen dass 99 prozent
der weiblichen bevölkerung in den
deutschen innenstädten prostituierte
sind das ist nämlich die einzige
erklärung dafür dass man irgendwelche
mädels oderstraße hingehen und die frage
ist ob man für 200 euro ihre titten
anfassen kann leute fangen wir mit dem
klassiker für 200 euro anfassen von band
freshen hier wurde zum euro dabei
dann geht ihr um und fragen jede
einzelne tusche ob sie bereit wären 11
200 euro wieder anfassen zu lassen
check your smile soweit denke da ist man
hier auch nicht verwerflich daran auf
die straße raus zu gehen und ganz
normale menschen zu fragen ob sie sich
für geld an in den intimsten stellen
begabten lassen würden kann ich nichts
schief gehen also erstmal das ganze
klarzustellen das ist ein trend der
höchstwahrscheinlich das habe ich in den
kommentaren schon gesehen aus amerika
kommt und ist aber alles cool so werden
die meisten youtube wahrscheinlich schon
gemacht dass irgendein trend in den usa
gesehen haben der dann ja viele klicks
gebracht habe den angenommen haben und
in deutschland eben etabliert hat aber
das ist echt schon verdammt hart leute
sowas soll letztlich das kommen 20 euro
auf den mund küssen oder für fünf euro
auf der straße schwängern würdet ihr
euer
anfassen was sie für 200 euro das geil
ist ja auch erlebt so hin und sagte so
jung kann ich vielleicht für 200 euro
oder ein arsch anfassen und dann sagt
sie selbstverständlich nein natürlich
weil man sonst sagen so rödiger ich bin
auch gerade auf dem weg eine
prostituierte zu werden so da ich kann
ich mit ihr die erste erfahrung sondern
vielmehr noch komplett mit mir nach
hause gehen oder so
in dem fall ich nicht habe mich auch
gewundert aber seine reaktion ist die
allerbeste weil er wirklich so wie nah
warum bist du 200 euro ist dafür 200
euro wie viel kostet 20 punkten chicken
nuggets 10 oder kann man sich 400
schicken dafür hohe 200 euro würde ich
eher so 20 stunden kellnern gehen da
jeder eine andere meinung bzw
es hat eigentlich keine andere meinung
weil alle in dem video gesagt haben das
ist dieses video für zwei euro dieser
titel leider dass dieses video für 200
euro verfassen man muss sagen das video
ist an sich schon menschen nicht gesehen
nicht abgeschlossen aber man muss diesen
bettwäsche an sicherheit geben dass ein
ganz guter entertainer ich und er macht
es ihr natürlich das ist gut video idee
vielleicht so vielleicht noch mal bei
denken aber nur eine anregung also nur
ist liegt nicht an mir darüber zu
urteilen was auf dem kanal masse aber
vielleicht so 30.000 bis 40.000 also kam
ganz einfach wenn du willst aber leute
das war längst nicht alles ich habe für
euch noch einen weiteren aus dieser
bandbreite an kann rausgesucht und zwar
für 100 euro dotierten anfassen schon
gespannt was denkt was ich denn die
machen so scheiß viele klicks alter was
soll das denn man sonst will ich noch
nicht drüber reden wenn es irgend ein
relevanter trend werde oder so aber
einfach so 1,5 millionen klicks mit
einer kommt mit 50.000 abos und die
logik ist dann immer leute wenn man dazu
was sagt dann und nicht selbst 158 1,63
millionen klicks macht dann ist man
natürlich automatisch neidisch wird weil
man wenn man nicht mindestens eine woche
dort 1,63 millionen klicks macht gar
nicht verstehen kann welchen sinn dieses
video hat und warum es dieses video gibt
das selbst eben erst ab 15 166 400 euro
würdest du einem großen fass machen
gute es wird auf jeden fall von dieser
frau wir so etwas sollte man das macht
und das eigentlich genau die richtige
antwort eigener körper so man kann
selbst bestimmen was man damit macht was
würdest du das eigentlich über die
gleiche sache leute und eine sache die
auch jetzt in den beiden videos hier
gezeigt habe gleich es ist dass die
hütte am anfang zu sagen so jung ansage
an alle youtuber die uns hätten ihr spaß
die smoothies jetzt wirklich schiesst
kein grund uns zu helfen was ein relativ
stark gewundert weil die jungs
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon genug kritik
dafür abbekommen für das was sie gerade
machen aber eben trotzdem weitermachen
der moment wenn ihr irgendwas macht was
bisschen kritisch ist ein bisschen an
schließlich ist macht einfach in dem
youtube-video wo es macht eine ansage
gegen alle die euch dafür kritisieren
und dann dann ist eigentlich auf einmal
automatisch richtig oder definitiv in
allen guten geistern verlassen ich habe
sicher denn schon gezeigt also die
displays gehen bei sowas immer richtig
krass ab aber richtig gestört dazu nur
unter dem video vom band fresh sind die
kommentare richtig aber ultra es gibt ja
was denn los mit dem selbst beschreibt
aber so kommentar like wenn du dir
hitler zu ihr gefühl das kann man kaum
beschreiben 2017 alles klar leute für
die jury ist ich glaube noch uneinig
schauen erst mal weiter so kommentare
wie was für ein bastard gehören auf
jeden fall noch zu haben unseren seite
denn wir haben jedoch gibt eine mutter
ihre kinder jugend und natürlich jede
menge nach die kommentare das ist
richtig krass einer band vorgesehen ist
eben farbig ja und da gehen paar leute
darauf ein um arbeitet das ist auch
nicht schlecht wieder zwei besonders
schüler hier haben wir zum beispiel den
schönen kommentar von haydn teppich wenn
hitler da wärst du nicht in deutschland
das wäre es auch falsch damit er
mitgeschrieben eigentlich aber auch kein
prediger ansonsten ist der kommentar in
vollkommen unproblematisch studieren wir
sagen ja aber jetzt schon dass das ultra
rassistisch mal ein komplett gestört auf
beiden seiten auf der seite von leute
die diese videos machen genauso wie auf
der seite von denen die solche
kommentare schreiben was geht denn mit
euch ab was kann man zum abschluss dort
zu sagen leute diese allgemeine
einstellung ist einfach preis heute das
ist einfach köstlich das ist wirklich
menschen gibt die denken so jeder mensch
oder die meisten menschen verkaufen so
für 100 euro ab
ein professionell gewerbe und der
prostituierten sieht das anders aus aber
man kann auf der straße die gavotte und
auch nicht ganz so geil ist dass man
einfach die straße geht unsere mädels
anlage und dann so mit der annahme
rangeht dass alle mädels so für 100 oder
200 euro zu kaufen sind so also was soll
man dazu sagen deswegen zum abschluss
dieses videos heute nochmal die umfrage
würdet ihr für 300 euro ein leichter
lassen könnte ja einfach mal machen
indem man einfach mal live auf dem video
da lass ich warte jetzt einfach nur noch
auf das video würdest du für 20 cent
eine linke lunge spenden leute und bis
dahin hier könnte ein carabiniere hier
könnte er persönlich mit vorgeschlagen
video abchecken irgendwas zu schauen und